Alors, ça te plaît? Tu aimes bien?
Ah oui, c'est pas mal.
- C'est pas mal.
- Ouais.
C'est mieux que l'ancien, en tout cas.
Tu veux un café, un truc?
Non, fais-moi faire le tour, d'abord.
OK?
Le tour, c'est facile.
Canapé, table.
Minimum vital: télé, console.
Tu vas mettre des étagères?
Oui, plus tard, nan ?
Petit test.
Mur?
- Porteur.
- Oui.
Mur?
- Pas porteur.
- Exactement.
Du coup, lequel tu perces
pour mettre des étagères?
- Le pas porteur.
- Même si la femme de ta vie
te demande de percer un mur porteur,
pour rien au monde, Riadh,
tu perces un mur porteur.
Je n'ai pas de meuf, donc je ne vais pas percer.
Eh bien, heureusement.
C'est validé?
C'est semi-validé.
- OK, on passe à la suite?
- Allez!
OK, c'est parti!
Ah, par contre, la cuisine…
- Elle n'est pas mal?
- Ah oui, c'est très très validé.
Tu me fais un café, s'il te plaît?
Oui, pas de souci, je te fais un café.
Juste, le café, il coule direct
dans le bac de récupération.
Donc je te fais un café à ma façon.
OK.
Je vais plutôt prendre de l'eau,
si ça ne te dérange pas.
Prends de l'eau. Le frigo, il est là.
Pourquoi ton eau est chaude,
tu veux me faire un thé?
Non, le frigo, il ne fonctionne pas trop.
Il y a le haut qui est chaud et le bas qui est froid.
Mon chat, je suis désolée,
mais déjà, ce n'est pas logique.
Ensuite, toutes tes courses, elles sont foutues.
Ça consomme une énergie monstrueuse.
Tu n'es pas prêt à vivre tout seul.
Tu ne veux pas habiter en colocation
avec quelqu'un?
Je ne sais pas, Bérenger,
tu ne veux pas habiter avec Riadh?
Oui, tu as deux lits?
J'ai peur d'aller voir la salle de bain.
On peut s'arrêter là,
on n'est pas obligés d'aller voir la salle de bain.
C'est...
c'est fonctionnel.
- Ah oui?
- Fonctionnel, oui.
Elle marche encore, ton antiquité?
Il faut la mettre à 40 degrés.
Mais fais gaffe parce que la dernière fois,
je l'ai retrouvée à l'autre bout de la pièce.
Tu as nettoyé le filtre?
Quel filtre ?
Oh, Riadh.
Il y a un filtre, il faut le nettoyer de temps en temps
parce que sinon, ça fait des..
C'est quoi, ça?
Tu ne peux pas nettoyer tes vêtements là-dedans.
C'est quoi, ce réacteur de fusée?
En fait, c'est de la récup. C'était à ma mère.
Franchement, c'est dangereux
et ce n'est pas très écolo.
Tu penses à mes enfants?
- Tu n'as pas d'enfant.
- Non, mais bon, on ne sait jamais.
Tu vois, dans le doute.
- Je vais aller acheter de l'électroménager.
- Merci.
Bon, on va regarder l'électroménager
comme à ce qui paraît, ma machine, elle est éclatée.
Ça coûte cher de ouf, ça.
Marion, c'est normal que ça coûte une blinde?
Oui, c'est normal, mais là, tu n'as plus trop le choix.
Je vais appeler le conseiller,
il doit avoir de bons plans.
Oui, c'est Riadh.
Vous avez quelques minutes à m'accorder?
Bien sûr, Monsieur Belaïche.
- L'emménagement se passe bien?
- L'appart est nickel, c'est super.
Juste, est-ce que vous avez des plans
pour l'électroménager?
Tout à fait.
Sur l'application Check,
il y a de bons plans
sur toute une sélection d'électroménagers.
Riadh, la machine essaie de m'attaquer!
Je crois qu'on vous appelle.
Riadh, viens!